We are here with Reese Witherspoon.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Now, actually, we do a thing here called "The Final Five",
but instead of me asking you,
we're gonna turn it to the nurses in the audience
and they're gonna ask the question.
Yeah.
(Drew talks indistinctly)
(drum roll)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yay.
All right, Alex, where are you?
I'm right here.
Kicking it off with you, go.
What is the best gift
you opened on Christmas morning as a kid?
Oh, that's a great question.
I have to say, the year I got Teddy Ruxpin.
(audience laughs)
Does anybody remember Teddy Ruxpin?
I loved...
It was this bear
and you could put a cassette tape
and it would say the words of the story,
but then I felt like guilty about it
'cause it was really hard to get a Teddy Ruxpin, (laughs)
so I really played with Teddy Ruxpin every day.
Right.
Every day.
Thank you, Alex, so much for your perfect question.
Next up, we have Ardeas.
Right here, what is your-
Hello.
What is your favorite outfit you kept from "Legally Blonde"?
Oh, okay.
I had, it's actually from "Legally Blonde 2"
and it's a pink suit that, it's like a little twin set
and it has a pillbox hat.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's like Chanel,
Jackie Kennedy.
Very Jackie.
I know exactly the one.
Yes.
Thank you Ardeas.
Okay, next we have Megan.
Hi.
Hi, Megan.
My question is when
is the last time you almost peed yourself from laughing?
(all laugh)
Maybe a few minutes ago.
We don't know, I have three children, guys.
(audience laughs)
Totally, totally.
Not sure, that's why she was asking me about laughing,
but laugh, I just laugh every day.
I mean, literally I get so tickled.
Thank you Megan so much.
Next up, Sam.
Hi.
Hi, Sam.
Hi, how are you?
You look very cute.
Oh, thank you.
I'm just saying.
Dapper Sam.
Thank you.
So my question is what's one thing that you do
that embarrasses your kids?
Hmm, one?
Yeah.
(both laugh)
Where do I begin?
I just, I'm more, I'm so...
They're mortified by me.
Whether it's like, I always ask them
what new slang terms are like yeet.
What is yeet?
Yeet?
I don't know.
(audience laughs)
Or they'll say like, no cap.
Do you say that or is that nerdy?
I also grab my kids' tushies everywhere.
Oh.
And then I'm also like,
I will wake up in the morning
and I'll be serving them cereal and a song will come on
and I'll be like, yeah.
Yeah.
Do a thing like that
and literally they're eating their cereal.
(audience applauds)
I just think like, you know, I have this theory.
If you're not embarrassing your children,
you're probably not spending enough time with them.
Do you know what I'm saying?
And one day,
they'll appreciate that dance that you did. (laughs)
Yeah, thank you, dapper Sam.
And last, Jackie.
Hi.
Hi, Jackie.
So my question for you is, what did you do
when you were younger that got you grounded the most?
Ooh.
Oh.
Definitely fighting with my brother.
Yeah, and I also, you know,
I started businesses when I was a little girl
and I got suspended, not suspended,
well, yeah suspended, kept after school
to have to clean desks because I was so creative
and I brought paint pens to school and I got them everywhere
'cause I started a business out of my desk in third grade
where I customized barrettes.
And I definitely got a lot,
I got in a lot of trouble at school.
Well, it didn't hold you back.
Now, you have this extraordinary singing voice.
I mean, you won an academy award
for "Walk the Line".
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
There were two moments in that film
that really struck me.
It's when Joaquin starts singing as Johnny Cash
and at first, it's a little warbly and you're seeing like,
and then all of a sudden it's like your skin melts off with.
Yeah.
He becomes and he embodies.
He really transforms, yeah.
And when you come out
on that stage and you sing
that almost lullaby-esque song as June,
and we already loved you at that moment,
but the musicality of that brought us in even more.
And I feel like that's when people were like,
"Yup, this is getting the award.
There's no question about this."
Oh, that's so sweet, thank you.
When you matriculate that into a fun movie, like "Sing"
and you embody Rosita, who just has the best storyline ever,
when she's doing like the gypsy Kings.
Yeah.
In the supermarket
and finds her inner strength.
Oh my gosh,
just wait 'til you see this next one.
What do we have to look forward to
because I have every song on "Sing" on soundtrack on repeat.
Oh, my God, I'm so excited.
(indistinct) 500 times, it's our very favorite.
What can we look forward to this one?
I can't wait to, y'all see it.
You have to call me the minute you watch it.
I will.
I just saw it in a theater
with a bunch of little children.
I have never been in a movie
where I watched kids stand up, sing, and dance
at every musical number.
And there was a little girl that's sitting in front of me
in her daddy's lap, and she goes, "Go, Rosita."
Oh, my God, (indistinct), it was so cute.
Okay, well, we have a clip from "Sing 2".
I mean, give it to me now.
I can't even...
I can't wait to see
which one is it.
Listen, you guys.
I have dreamt of performing in Red Short City
since I was a little kid.
And besides, I just convinced my husband to babysit
for the next 24 hours and I am not gonna waste
an opportunity like that.
So come one.
We've got nothing to lose.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We cheer for Rosita.
We cheer for you.
I cheer for you as my friend.
I cheer for you as what you are doing
and changing the world and putting out there.
I love you very much.
Love you very much.
Reese Witherspoon, be sure you catch her
in "Sing 2".
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Today.
(upbeat outro music)